hi my name is karl my question for you
kind of relates back to how you're
raising money for your foundation the
American Foundation for equal rights
which is fighting prop 8 thank you again
also for doing all your work I'm from
California myself and really appreciate
everything that you're doing thank you
my question for you is how do you go
about raising that money or is it more
from a wide base of people with small
donations or is it more from maybe big
donors who write the big checks well
it's a combination of both of those
things which you know in in philanthropy
and in money raising in general and
political campaigns you know you always
hear both you always need the graph you
want the grassroots you need the people
who are out there writing the
fifty-dollar checks and the
hundred-dollar checks in large numbers
and with a political campaign or even
with the American Foundation for equal
rights which is a court case but public
opinion is you know does come into play
in a court case it is something in times
at times that the judges the judge or
judges depending on the court will keep
in mind especially on social justice
issues